you know we should fix her up with her
nieces son what's his name - doctor Oh
Vince and he's not a doctor is a
pharmacist although that might appeal to
an kid and who should we fix him up with
her
oh now sell you know I'm still getting
over the tragic loss of my wife she was
such a strong female woman with nice
heavy breasts who's that oh that's my
neighbor hey Larry ah hey Greg Greg
ah that was it Lester I have so much
trouble remembering probably because our
relationship is so casual morning ladies
hi
oh I do it laughs without me I need to
talk to Larry about an issue with our
shared fence Larry I need to talk to you
about an issue with our shared fence yes
I also need to discuss this shared fence
issue with you okay they're out of
earshot
why are you absolutely no reason just
excited to face a new day oh because
ever since we've been down here you've
been a little depressed
don't eat the burrito
[Music]
okay fine I may have had a teensy bit of
trouble adjusting when we first got here
for like 16 see little months but I took
your advice and I got a job doing what I
sell ATVs now yeah well the truth is
these little babies sell themselves
they're super fun and they're a lot
safer than you might think if you're
standing next to one if you're driving
it it's actually much more dangerous
than you could possibly imagine
well a job is good I know being stuck
down here in Florida isn't ideal but we
need to make the best of it in fact I'm
applying for a promotion at my new job
ah very nice and if all goes well
tonight you might be neighbors with Greg
Stickney assistant manager very double
noise well I'm off to work you might
want to stand back cut in the black zone
here want to forget the strap safety
first
Greg Larry what's going on
any idea why Marshall HUS called this
special meeting I don't know do you
think she saw the video we put on the
internet to lure Jimmy Figgis down here
corn dog pinned by go-cart its pwned but
that was really adorable well she has it
would ruin our entire plan vision homes
gentlemen so so how's it going it's good
it's really good keeping a low profile
in no one's questioned our identities
definitely staying off the net right
Craig right that's it that's all you
have to say to me yeah I think we're
good so nobody's gonna ask me how I'm
doing
oh I didn't think this was a personal
conversation it's not turned back away
I'm watching movie this is official
business I was just testing you because
Greg is the kind of person who cares
about his friends and can sense when
something is off with him
is something off with you Marshall house
I don't know what I mean
I met someone okay and um I mean it's
not my husband I mean nothing's happened
yet but my entire body is on fire he's
Cuban is this still official business of
course it is shut up and watch a movie
yeah pop quiz if Larry were married and
everything was fine and I mean honestly
everything is totally fine but he knew
that one night what this person could
give him everything he needed for the
rest of his life
why'd he do it yes yes good what if this
person that Larry met was young I mean
really young well I don't think Larry
would do anything illegal you know it
seems to me Larry has needs and deserves
to have those needs met
Gregg you're really great at being
undercover no you both pass the test
let go let me not hey everyone
sorry I'm late so what's this secret
meeting all about you guys know I'm not
medically cleared for another week it's
not a secret meeting Jake it's an
intervention the tips have to go what
why Jake we're worried about you and you
look very stupid come on guys
I think they're kind of cool retro no
they're terrible Amy come on
you're digging the tips right no I feel
like I'm kissing Vanilla Ice there was a
time you would have jumped at that
chance they have to go all right you
guys got me I did it as a joke I kept
them ironically pretty funny right I
went too deep down there in Florida at
one point I think I forgot where the tip
of me ended and the base of the tips
began before we just chopped them off
would anybody like to say some final
words no that was one word that counts
Thank You Rosa okay I'm ready sorry I'm
late everyone but trust me it's worth it
me and Jake are chip buds
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you know what I do see it it's mad at
what's bad attention squad pretty dainty
way to make an announcement it's a
workplace I wanted to be respectful well
as someone at a high risk for a spook
related death thank you as I was saying
it's time for round four of the
Halloween Jake Peralta here to tell you
that tonight is the night for the
Halloween price Amy already went over
this
what games what are you doing I always
announce the highest yeah Amy what the
hell are you doing exercising my right
to announce the heist as the defending
champion defending champion the only
reason you won is cuz no one knew you
were even playing it was a pathetic act
of pure cowardice oh she's your
girlfriend well not tonight she isn't
although don't kiss anyone else I love
you so much
now then this one's for all attention
squad tonight don't y'all three really
should have coordinated it what I really
should be the one to introduce the heist
as the last legitimate champion perrault
hasn't won since the first year ISA has
been yeah well this has been has been
with yo mama all week sorry I feel like
I crossed a line I apologize everyone we
know the heist is happening no my
ex-wife just died No thank you for
joining me for what promises to be the
diggity dopest tree-lighting in the
history of the nine-nine
I don't understand where's the tree it
was inside us all along
brilliant Jake no Charles not everything
was inside of us all along the tree is
right here
cool can we go now obviously not behold
the greatest inflatable tree that murica
has to offer and now in the immortal
words of st. Nick turn on the compressor
here that the sound of Christmas it's
deafening it's getting really big what's
I treated you get it's a jumbo they said
this 10 meters tall that's roughly
thirty two point eight one eight someone
unplug it unplug it now can't it's one
of his own
okay the tree has been contained
wait we left a man behind well
Terry's trapped in the break room
forever only thing we can do now is move
on with our lives is what Terry would
have wanted god bless us everyone good
morning everyone
oh my goodness Sarge
what are the chances I save zero
ah I mean when Genevieve gotten these
suspenders I thought I'd lean into it go
for the whole look but I didn't want to
step on your toes that being said you
know what this means don't do this
Charles oh it's already done
gather round y'all it's time to play who
wore best I'd really rather than because
you're a little chicken who wore it best
who wore it best who wore it best
Terry what come on you should change
Boyle not here
oh hello yes guys guys so check it out
Hitchcock who fell asleep in the break
room so I put his hand in a bowl warm
water
come on man that's the stupidest prank
ever ah no it's the smartest because it
involves biology I bet it worked already
let's go Jack
Hitchcock no he's drowning he's drowning
babe oh man take it back Jake great
friend in the world
great form captain your calves are
looking Toya Peralta what are you doing
there as much as we need to stop
somewhere outside the precinct yes you
were here too great sir we've discovered
a lieutenant Hawkins is dirty squad is
an investigator with golden gang bank
robbers they are the robbers sorry
Brenda Hipparchus is robbing banks why
she invite you onto a task force we're
working on a case that could have
exposed her this way she can keep tabs
on us turn it get down yeah why is this
so hard for me do I even have quads and
normally I'd say we'd report this to
internal affairs
but Hawkins is one of the most revered
detectives in the NYPD is you gonna go
after her you better have the proof to
back it up well then I guess that only
leaves us one option and now wag those
tails
find out everything we can about the
squad and take her down from the inside
keep wagging wagging Brenda
you